[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
friends union old welcome to the Medici
family circuits where anything is
possible and miracles happen
[Music]
[Applause]
introducing our world-famous
just when I thought I have seen
everything what do you think of that
how is your indifference right you won't
find another sucker
right-wing check left-wing check prepare
for takeoff
all right Dumbo give me a showstopper
[Applause]
he's making a child again
coming
said a monkey on your desk just for
emergencies
don't be scared don't be scared now your
mama's right outside
[Music]
baby
[Music]
what is that baby jumbo look at me do
what I do
hello no not the feather your ears blow
he thinks it's a game let me have a
drink
[Music]
[Music]
I'd like to offer you a drink and Cunha
[Music]
said a monkey in your desk just for
emergencies
look mr. Vandermeer I probably should
tell you
the elephant is not for sale Dumbo will
only fly for the Medici circus that's
assuming he is real slides isn't what
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome it's for the record this is not
my idea number works alone mortal Billy
Joe and you jamming
well maybe didn't recognize me without
makeup so I gotta teach you to fly I
know how to fly ever since it was a
child they thought Dumbledore I know so
I don't move too expensive
alright
[Music]
welcome baby gumbo all family here no
matter how small
[Music]
[Music]
yes something very rare you have wonder
[Music]
you have to stick
you have magic
[Music]
come with me
together we can soar on the elephant's
wings
what's happening were they taking her
take them go back inside but she's his
mom do something she needs us look at me
we're gonna bring your mama huh
he doesn't look like magic to me
[Music]
your children need you to believe
you can do a Dumbo show
[Applause]
fly baby
[Music]
Dumbo is a lot of fun
we got a flying elephant come on how
much more fun can you add I loved the
original version this is a new modern
take on it the original ends with the
elephant flying and this version would
be gives of that the story of a circus
family in disarray
[Music]
the birth of this baby elephant makes
them come together in a magical way Tim
Burton is directing he understands
outsiders people who don't fit him
vulnerable souls like Dumbo this film
has such an extraordinary visual life
the caller is a sounds
the set was enormous tim filled us with
performers from all over the world you
had hundreds of extras jugglers and
tumblers it's pure magic I've never done
anything quite like this I feel like I'm
dreaming sometimes I got such goosebumps
when I walked onto the set for the first
time this was unbelievable
we need this movie right now it's such a
powerful universal story anything is
possible
it reaffirms that individuality is a
good piggy you don't need to be perfect
to be loved you could do it
[Applause]
why
[Music]
don't you try
look at that we're all family here no
matter how small
[Music]
[Music]
shoulder
[Music]
I leave a movie Dumbo bits one Tim
Burton's most beautiful movies it's
truly beautiful
the film has such an extraordinary
visual life to us the colors the magic
it was a great world to live in making
the movie it's just a joy to be on set
every day I mean it was it was magic let
me put it to you this way Danny and I
are walking onto the set we enter this
huge huge building literally you could
have put an entire dome baseball stadium
in it was so big freak them out and we
both stopped and literally a chill ran
up the back of my neck
there aren't that many times one is ever
gonna have that kind of experience and
you know making a movie anymore and
within that space tim filled us with
performers from all over the world from
acrobats to jugglers i mean i had to
pinch myself all the time I felt like I
was dreaming sometimes working with Tim
it's such a good experience to be around
that kind of creativity tim understands
Outsiders people who don't fit in and
Dumbo is the classic example of that
scope of Dumbo with the artistry of Tim
Burton it is gonna be amazing on the
biggest screen you can see it on
[Music]
they feel
[Music]